look i grew up in the early 90s watching
snl dude and yeah you know i mean this
is going to segue into talking about
your family and your brother and
everything but
on my mount rushmore of life is your
brother and adam sandler of life dude oh
really like i used to do stand-up comedy
i had to transition out of it because i
wanted to make money at some point
but yeah you don't do it yeah you know
you're out doing it
and making money making things but i
just remember in middle school running
around just getting there like
everything like yeah it's you know it'd
be like what i said like you're your
favorite baseball player of all time
juan gonzalez like meeting you meaning
the entire gonzales family would be a
big deal for you so
no yeah uh
there's still a lot of people you know
that uh
remember him and that's why i made the
documentary because i wanted to show
people you know what he was like and
that there's a lot of been said about
chris and that kind of thing i kind of
wanted to
set the record straight a little bit on
on some of that stuff and it was uh yeah
it was a those are it was a great
documentary i was i was happy with it
you know well let me ask you your you
guys are less than a year separated what
is it yeah no chris was like a year yeah
it's called irish twins right irish yeah
so you know i think he's like a month a
year like a month
uh older than i am yeah which is crazy
so
your older brother one year apart is
chris farley legendary yeah but like you
have a lot of what he had we're like
irish twins exactly kevin questions so
so when i think very different i'm like
chris farley light you know i'm not
going to throw myself on a tape no
exactly
so yesterday we're we're uh hanging out
at this event and we're talking to
pampliano right
bitcoin and i'm asking about his family
five brothers how they're doing and he's
telling the story massive guy in the
bitcoin yeah he's he yeah he is and he's
but all the five brothers they're all
doing something right from 26 the
youngest to 33 being him the oldest
they're all players they're all killers
yeah and i said so tell me about the
household growing up well how was dad
like how was mom like and see how dad
was a worker six days a week but mom ran
the show and i said but tell me about
the whole you know dynamics cause i got
four kids yeah what was the farley
household like growing up that's what i
want to know yeah all the brothers too
right yeah no there's one
sister yeah who's actually the funniest
um you know it was a lot of like because
we had four boys in the basement you
know we had a house that had a basement
we didn't have it upstairs so it was
kind of like living in a dungeon area
like sorry i don't know but we also
wisconsin was cold
and i think a lot of comedians come from
like canada and wisconsin because you're
trapped inside
and there's no other thing to do other
than like we didn't have a lot of things
growing up you know other than
i'm gonna try to make you laugh you know
or else i'm gonna try to make you laugh
or i'm going to do something and then we
dare
always darings i dare you to do that i
dare you that and we'd make up games
like does this hurt you know
she's pretty simple you don't want to
lose at that game
pretty simple game you know the oldest
to youngest give us the rundown well
there's barb who's the oldest she was
the older sister she had her own section
of the house yeah so we couldn't go over
there she had carpenter's albums that we
couldn't touch and that kind of thing
and then uh then they had the rest of us
just kind of like piled in an area we'd
switch like once one of us would get in
a fight and then i'd have to room with
john and then you know one of us to get
another fight we'd have to room with
chris there's three boys one girl four
boys four boys yeah yeah gotcha and and
what what are the age gaps before boy
for someone there chris farley you think
he'd know his bible to be honest yeah i
know i know chris and kevin that's who i
know first i'm hearing that barbara's
the most funny
two we get to kevin's cousin john's the
older brother yeah john's the john's the
older brother right john john's youngest
he's the only young guy then i have a
brother tom and then a brother chris and
then myself and then john and how many
years separate there's only a couple
years yeah dude what did it happen to
you you guys went to middle school high
school all at the same time pretty much
yeah what was that like i mean a
football team you know parties keg this
basement what was all that like it was
you know i think that i look at kids
growing up now and i'm like i kind of
feel bad like
we were out a lot like i'd be like sir
i'm out of here you know and i'd go be
with my friends for hours and i don't
know i never went home or anything i
never went in front of the television
you know we had to make up our own fun
in our own and when when the vcr hit
they were like oh wow i'm going to watch
this all day long
but no we were making our own fun like
we're out in the out and playing
basketball or making up our own games or
trying to usually chris was always the
funniest like we could make him do
anything you know what i mean we could
he would do anything like anything like
anything no it's like you know you you
make these dares where you go i dare you
do this i dare you to that you know i'm
not gonna do that like he'd do that
craziest there he ever yeah what's the
craziest there no i don't know
you know running you know this simple
one was running around the block naked
you know which is that's just how good
that ever you know
it's pretty simple i mean but but it
takes it's not a very you know nobody
came up with the idea like really
thought about the idea
but it was the most dangerous thing yeah
because you're ultimately going to get a
call from the neighbor going hey
chris is running around naked again but
think about it if you're an expert at
physical comedy which he was yeah i mean
that had to be the funniest sight and
you couldn't get mad right you know you
see chris farley running down you know
doing a whole mile around you know and
then he had the he had to complete the
thing though you had to you can't bank
out of the dare yeah nobody likes these
stairs when we made these dares you had
to
complete the day now were you the one
you couldn't back out were you the one
mostly daring him to do the thing or
like what was your i wasn't what was
your involvement i was a chicken i would
make the game up yeah i would help make
the game but i'd never do the thing he
was always doing those you're the
producer and he's yeah
i would get the credit
but by the way what's the story with dad
that was like an instigator he would
come in he would like hey
it seems like he was he was uh also
orchestrating a little bit of this a lot
of that he would be one of those things
where he he had five kids that he'd rile
up and then and then get him into a
frenzy and then walk out the room and be
like all right let my mom handle it
but he was uh an asphalt salesman so he
he sold asphalt for a living and
you know if you ever see an asphalt crew
that's like 120 degrees on the road then
we would sell the oil for the asphalt
and so you know it was tough and if we
didn't do good at school you'd be like
i'll get you on the asphalt crew if you
like
i'm like no right there's the ultimate
third pat you know kevin's stand-up
routine is awesome and a lot of it you
talk about you know your family you talk
about chris
he's got one joke where he talks about i
got to find out if this was a joke or if
this really happened the joke you had
where chris came back for christmas with
sex toys for everybody yeah yeah he
thought it'd be really funny you know
and and he's like yeah i got this is
going to be funny i'm going to give
everybody a sex toy and i go yeah that's
not going to be funny you know you're
going to you're going to ruin christmas
and he bought too many of them 100 you
said he bought 100 sex toys back and so
after you opened up the first one you're
like okay i gotta you know i got a sex
toy and then and then you open up like
20 of them
you said dad's not gonna like this and
he brought this for mom dad the brother
the whole works everyone gets a sexy
yeah and the joke ran out about after
the third president you know and then
we're all just kind of like now you've
got to go to the hospital or something
else so he just ran around the block
naked there's something wrong with you
so then he just ran around how old is he
when this story happened
he was uh old too old to know like
probably in college okay gotcha yeah i
was too old to be doing that yeah no i
can only imagine the reaction you need
to come home like if i did that with my
dad what my dad's reaction would be the
funniest thing about him is that he
would do those things where he thought
he legitimately thought it was gonna be
funny and i'm like this is gonna miss
the mark on such a level that is like
wow this is gonna be so embarrassing
it's gonna be great
and he was just but he'd still commit to
the joke and that was part of his comedy
where even though you weren't really
sure if this was going to be funny
but he would go so far into it that he
made it funny right even just because of
his commitment to it you know would you
have to applaud i mean yeah by the way
they didn't didn't in the documentary
that you produced didn't i don't know if
it was the ep or or the the producer who
was that said
he didn't just like comedians that were
funny he liked comedians that took a lot
of risks yeah and it seems like your
brother was a risk taker with a lot of
these things because some of this yeah
on stage yeah his life too but i mean on
stage he would always appreciate any
kind of comedy even like just to get up
there i mean he did stand up just to get
up there with a microphone or get up
there and do improv we were in the
improv in the second city and that kind
of thing chicago yeah we all did that
and so when an improv you just you're
starting out with nothing just like a
you know and a suggestion from the
audience and then everybody goes from
there and so just to get up there takes
a lot of guts it just does you know
instead it's it just takes a lot so he
always empathizes yeah if you gave it a
chance you know if you get up there and
you and you didn't try he didn't like
that you got to get up there and really
try take risks and and if you took a
risk you'd be like i love it you took a
risk it didn't work but who cares it's
about
trying it taking a risk on stage or
wherever you're doing it sure and that's
what separates the great ones because
everybody's up there you're feeling
naked right and you got to keep going on
and that's how you learn to persevere
and and come up with some some of the
good standby jokes about you is we had a
football coach uh that uh had this
saying which was funny like whenever you
know you had a play that you messed up
and then you'd go to the coach you're
like well i thought i needed to pull
this way and my coach would always go
well don't think do
and he goes if you're going to make a
mistake make an aggressive mistake chris
always used to say that you know would
that apply to stage where you're not not
sure what you're doing out there but
make that aggressive
and then you could kind of fake it
you're like i knew what i was doing
though did you play football as well
yeah so what positions were you guys no
we were all on the line because we were
too big let's get all the big boys on
the line yeah yeah we were not skilled i
could just see some farley's pulling
guards over there all right sweep left
no he's going we were all on the line
yeah we were all on the line there was
no skill position what was that like in
high school if you're you know he's in
10th grade you're in ninth grade or
whatever senior junior
locker room football like boys being
boys what was that like it was a
competition to see who could be the
funniest to me we valued funny guys yeah
and if you were a funny guy
in in our school or any of our friends
or even our family you you rose to the
top you know if you could make everyone
laugh because you know that was that was
to me
that was the goal to be the funny guy
the guy that was always making people
laugh
you know and he was always constantly
the winner of that he was he won that
every time you know and did you in your
grade like he was the funniest grade
were you i was in my grade yeah yeah i
was i learned from everyone just it
seemed natural you know being growing up
and trying to just make uh
make the other guys laugh and was
everybody trying to impress dad like
what was the impetus for everyone's
trying to be funny in the farley house
yes yeah it stems from my dad was very
funny really yeah and uh i think there
was always this you know you just want
to you know
uh
make the big guy laugh you know if you
could make the big guy laugh then you
were you were in good well then he's not
mad at you you know you're out because
you know it's not like we didn't get in
trouble because we if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]